if you can only bear to be around your
friends when you're drunk like you
definitely need better friends full stop
or make can't wait to shut down
Newcastle tonight horn emoji horn emoji
aubergine emoji then you know when
people get like a table and a bottle and
the first time that that becomes like
something you can afford to do and you
feel like such a big deal and then you
like the next morning you do yeah I've
been to a piece of 12 times and all that
you're doing when you go away and you
get that blind drunk is choosing what
destination and visuals you want to deal
with a hangover it if you ever had a
hangover once I think first time I tried
alcohol must have been a bit before that
which was a pint of gin extreme events
on nights hours seen as badges of honor
there's no other experience in which to
see University students would wring each
other and say hey man how was your night
last night and the other one goes may
it's amazing
John broke his leg
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by the mustachioed man himself
Yousef and Johnny from propene fitness
comm Joey from you so [ __ ] Johnny from
Yousef calm how are you good very good
thank you thank you for joining great
know we've circled around this topic for
ages we're talking about why sobriety
today all of us either by religious
doctrine or lifestyle choices and kind
of sober for extended periods and even
the man behind the camera video guiding
can feel a hot potato it's still up I'm
ready for it yeah the man behind the
camera video guy Dean is one week away
from a year sober which is a [ __ ] feet
and a half he thing was to form up two
feet yeah like [ __ ] laugh isn't it
rounded up to two feet so yeah why why
sobriety is an interesting question I
guess people who maybe haven't heard us
talk about this topic before might not
know what like why we even consider it
something to think about like I don't
see a problem with my drinking every
drinks I've always drank just a part of
society but some of the people will know
I've done episodes with Ed lightly more
than two with Tom MacGregor both of whom
a massive sobriety advocates Michael
Kaju whose it wasn't like addicted to
[ __ ] a heroin at the age of 14 and
stuff like that he's big into it but
yeah I just wanted to a lot of people
it's the most replied to content that I
power online about resetting people's
drinking habits I don't thought just how
many discussion about it be mmm pretty
valuable so what made you decide what
what way do you pick sobriety there's
something to do so three years ago
not just approaching three years ago and
I needed I just wait to do more stuff I
was kind of in a bit of a rut with where
I was at I was about studying CrossFit
that was one lifestyle change that I
made I was just like that
[ __ ] sick like I'm not doing I
thought life would be different than
this somehow and I need more time I
think I did this like analogy where I'd
sit down with an accountant at the end
of my year and look at how much time how
it could be me or Christine promise
Johnny because you do not ring me I know
I looked at my the amount of available
time that I have across a whole year and
if my accountant was looking at it he'd
say oh hang in a second what's like
every Saturday you lose a whole day then
every Sunday you lose half a day and
then every Monday you lose a quarter
every day in terms of productivity units
whatever you want to call it plus you're
spending all this money but see it's
killing you like it's making you live
sure it's not gonna make you live any
longer let's just thought if I stop
drinking I'll have more time to spend on
anything which isn't drinking another
big part of it was I get I get
increasingly about hangovers as I get
older which I think everybody does
another part of it was that it's
expensive I didn't feel like I had
anything left to learn from alcohol like
it is a drug which takes you to the
exact same place every single time yeah
and that's like one of the maddest
memories that I've got he's going away
to Vegas both times I've been away to
Vegas for four days the same four days
Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday fly back
on Thursday on both times I've learned
and unlearned the same lesson every 24
hours around about 3 p.m. arrive think
I'm invincible start drinking continue
to think of invincible wake up realize
I'm not hate myself think I should've
done that guess the 3 p.m. forget how I
felt on the morning remember how I felt
on the night get back on it yeah and the
mad thing is because when you get like
super super blackout drunk it takes you
to a place that's so overwhelming to all
of you senses that you literally could
have been in like the pub down the road
valuer yeah
I do feel that there's a there is some
kind of like moral obligation to do that
when you go to Vegas at least once
oh I think I think if you if you go to
Vegas you have a quiet time it's part of
the energy requirement yeah you've like
you've you've done it incorrectly you've
not had this not to enter a decision
yeah
to get the stamp in your passport you
have to have had that by expert time is
it not really sure let's drink mmm
I nearly ate a bowl of nice nut calamari
at 3 in the morning
in in a casino in Vegas it's not even a
thing not to caliber so I ordered
Calabar any pizza 3m history no I said
the way to just use leaving by the way
I've got knowledge anyone my god
he's like sir we cook everything in
peanut oil I love when Halloweeny
shouldn't rip out stories from Vegas
it's brilliant because you've got so
many germs like that would have killed
both of you if it was what's it I'm okay
with squid actually okay we can assess
yourself shellfish but yeah like you
when you go away you drink that heavily
and you have one of those party holidays
like I've done 30 20 30 or them my bear
my bear revita like I've been to a piece
of 12 times and every time I've gone
pretty much I've done that same thing
all that you're doing when you go away
and you get that blind drunk is choosing
what destination and visuals you want to
deal with a hangover it yeah
yeah that that God's honest truth and
this is coming from someone who was a
professional party boy but like 10 years
so that's it like this is this is the
thing that you did isn't it like this is
your you having a level of expertise in
drinking I was world-class level party
yes
so like since I did it
I've encouraged you to try and go sober
as well yeah and you did that three
months in spider 3 aren't you yep talk
me through your experience there what
sort of drinker were you before so I I
think my drinking definitely used to be
quite a big deal I got used to drink a
lot so it's a lot for it well I mean so
you need heavily three times a week four
times a week like obviously freshers
week I think the most I did there's a
story I can't say for various reasons
that there's a thing I did where I drank
every night for 14 nights in a row and
every night I began with a bottle of
home white Grenache gallo family white
corn hash why was that
so it's rose a wine from like the coop
it to be honest or for a bit of time you
just becomes so acclimatize I remember
drinking the entire bottle while playing
call of duty before going on this night
out and every time being getting
slightly better recorded you use the
night went on thinking this is having
less and less of an effect from the same
day yeah yeah in the same period of time
I first time hit a hit 140 bunch of
proud periods of mana it's the sea
surface but yeah so you study like that
so that very representative drinking
then and then what did you move into
when you were was oh it started in like
accountancy training in it it got quite
bad again to tape it off because like
you know you think like [ __ ] I've got to
actually get a degree here otherwise
this has been a major waste of time and
money so like got a degree start the job
and then it's like freshers again and
suddenly along with cigar again it
wasn't that back so you've got a good
work but it probably got more intense so
that's when Vegas happened twice you
don't want money note yeah and Andre
yeah suddenly you're like okay like the
previous material organizations of your
alcohol exam every other part of the
world I can have top-shelf spirits yeah
yeah and that became a thing like
ordering like it's such a dick thing you
know when people get like a table and a
bottle and the first time that that
becomes like something you can afford to
do and you feel like such a big deal and
then you like the next morning
wanker and then it slowly kind of
tapered off but I remember used to I
used to hate the idea and I think you'd
probably be the same I used to hate the
idea of like having a few beers in a pub
because I didn't see the point of that
but I absolutely saw the point of
getting off my foot wine drunk and I
told the story that you shared on the
beginning and cigarette of like tactical
puke in a in a in an alleyway mm-hmm
and that was like the best thing
happened what weekend for me oh I had a
point so I never realized to inject that
I totally forgot I'm on this sobriety so
little sort of stint at the moment but
my Master's dissertation was at the
effectiveness of an T alcohol
advertising of students at Newcastle
University I just totally forgot that
I've done that right if nothing reunify
see you're listening actually James
Quinn to go back and check it and check
his dissertation so I submitted my
before turn in he just changed the word
alcohol for smoking oh my god and they
retrospectively Hume and an F replace
like drinking smoking alcohol these guys
they can't retrospectively contribute so
mine was in before Turnitin was a thing
plus we were different you knees but he
submitted my dissertation turn it's not
like an ante plagiarism a usual thing
yet so and one of the things that I
discovered there was that students and
this is for everyone right especially in
the UK two big drinking culture there's
not a lot happening in the UK it's not
like [ __ ] America where there's
literally 50 countries within your
country and you can go to them all and
do different things and spend the same
money and everyone uses the same words
yeah the UK is an island
the weather's pretty [ __ ] there's not a
lot of sunlight there's not that much to
do really people drink
yep they need to drink to keep
themselves excited yeah what I realized
was two things first drink into rite of
passage for young people and that's
that's quite interesting like if you
want to be an older adult with
Representative experiences that allow
you to relate to other people you have
to drink when you're younger
because you need to know what it's like
to like have a drunken argument with you
girlfriend at 19 or lose your phone and
your keys stranded in Manchester and
have to find your way home because
that's a representative experience you
know I was half of it the other half of
it was the extreme events on nights
hours seen as badges of honor so like
there's no other experience in which to
see university students would ring each
other and say hey man how was your night
last night and the other one goes May
it's amazing John broke his leg me like
I don't yeah
why is that amazing oh because it's a
it's this marker of xxs films like The
Hangover have glorified taking
substances alcohol drugs whatever it
might be to excess and it's seen as like
I'm hard this is something to be proud
of this is something that's cool and um
yeah that like that just totally
reframed everything so you normal normal
drinking cadence mmm bit more of a
weekend warrior bit more money to spend
yeah and then that that's early tapered
off and I think probably where I was
when you suggest it to me it was like it
was more a couple of years than it was
getting blind pissed because I think
you've just you please I don't wear a
ski trip and was 16 right and the gym
the PE teacher big bloke like big thick
my like thick forums thick neck they're
like big bother you can imagine it was
like like 80s cop sunglasses just
stumbled on put it this way everyone
else is wearing like south pets and big
biggest ski whether he's wearing jeans
in a barber jacket just untouched by a
skin of like that real
a strongman they standing up and just
goes lads you know because it was legal
where we were drinking Austria you know
till it could not quit out with you have
a couple of beers but for heaven's sake
don't go silly with this right I've took
that to mean a couple I'm going silly
then had like a disciplinary chat with
me where he basically just said
you insolent I told you they're not cool
it was exactly what you did
yes that was silly but did you know I
have like five beers working but I was
like the first time I've got like really
dry legit yeah like really drunk was
brilliant but um so I was having like
probably a couple of beers the autumn
only out here and there but not was not
a serious but the thing that I thought
giving it up for three months the
biggest change was you realize just how
many by little things you go to where
the default would be three beers four
beers and then you add that up like [ __ ]
over like three weeks I've had you know
20-hour many calories from alcohol or
you know that you wake up the next day
you're a bit fuzzy that's the odd time
way wake up yeah I probably shouldn't
drive and you just think I haven't
really I couldn't quantify the game
because in a way like if you go to Vegas
and you get blind pissed at least you've
got all those stories and if you just
have a few beers and then have like a
few conversations where the other
person's had four beers as well and it
would be in exactly the same
conversation
if you've both been sober yeah well all
I've had is downside here but cost
calories lost time lost like for the
colonisation yeah and I suppose it makes
it like it takes the edge off a little
bit doesn't it which is why people do it
yeah like why do people drink they get
something out of it at the time and we
live in a society where people make very
short-term decisions and ignore the
long-term cost so that that's why it's a
problem it is it's the reason that
people choose to drink is for a whole
host of reasons but one of the one of
the main ones is that there
the games are a media and the costs are
in the future
tomorrow on Myra's product future
Youssef will deal with this hangover
you ever had a hangover once yeah
so though we drag an entire populace
spirit
surprisingly not it was so there's a lot
about don't tell me was after I made you
drink that rum know about this that was
fun okay that there's a lot of backstory
to this first off when was your first
ever drink twice so I can remember I
remember your first beer was the first
year yeah I was with Johnny Weir at a
marketing event maggoty standing in a
room full of personal trainers mmm guy
hands out everyone Stella Artois they
said this is right Stella is either
Stella or the coroner corona and
yourself like takes a sip trying to
sneak in and the guy goes guys you're
interesting in itself that people
applauded you're now part of yeah yeah
you've joined so what was your first
beer 22d say no to I think 25 I never
drank not a drop was that the first bit
of alcohol yeah yeah and then so that
was a 30 minute cocktail had a cocktail
but I was kind of like and then I think
it was i before after and i remember
that the first time i prompt first time
i tried alcohol must have been a bit
before that which was a pint of gin neat
yeah and so I've drunk much worse than
like with Johnny and I have drunk
horrible supplements over the years
there yeah but to be otherwise the same
they're not meet gin yeah it's like
alcohols up there with like you know I'm
really yeah rose width was like is that
Jim you just drunk like why how are you
not like you do just have a tendency to
go because when Creek Chris bought
yourself a nephews 80% integral room
yeah a double and and these have
standing the bar just went yeah it's
quite strong everyone else goes like
turns everyone else its face it
yeah just neutral expression I think I'm
so used to hydrolyzed casein the average
mean it's worse I think it's different
isn't it it's got more more immediate I
think yeah so that's interesting like
for us as a representative such and
representative group of people to be
talking about alcohol I was like
infrequent but hard you were consistent
and sort of low-level with somehow I
think I was that yeah I was younger I
was that in it it slowly kind of changed
at the time and then you were someone
who was sober for so but what did you
think of party culture when you were
aliens for the last visit I found it so
exhausting I would always be the boring
old man like one am NOT gonna try and
like I'll tell the priest who ties the
story as well but the the gin was just
like in my mind
alcohol was something that is a drug I
can get many spectrum of of drugs
possible and so I just thought like okay
how would I try a drugs now by units I
would take a therapeutic dose of it keep
in there in a bonus and then wait for
the result and see what happens
minister it in the most efficient manner
that I kiss there's like why can't go IV
I'll have to just i'll find what's what
to concentrate a drink that's quite
something so have that and then like
just didn't holy chaos the rest of the
night and its most similar to like you
know you were saying like you have you
had like a few beers you know hours a
bit rubbish and there's a lot of
calories and fluid uh-huh Harry
potter-themed chief and where I was like
the men are handsome as approaches that
you on till frog Lords alcohol as much
as possible so you your stuff is an
empty stomach and you have eight units
and then you stop and then
time ago - menu and what was the alcohol
is metabolized in your go to mid-fight
so yeah then the time the hang of it was
just post I did a sports massage therapy
course and it was around then yeah and
with the guy Atticus pull out for drinks
at the end and he was like oh I use
about I get you drinking I don't really
drink Nick ok man's drink
I would speckle then you would love it
you thought you were great old Speckled
Hen have you have you both had yeah for
someone that already thinks beer is just
a scam like it's just some of the like
dishwater in it so how did I was like
Nick this is the worst thing I've ever
drunk who's like now like throughout the
night then they would giving me like red
wine and white wine and lagers and I
think the mixture the waiter said yeah
it was quite vom II how every but really
only two three episodes of alcohol in my
life it's never it's never really stuck
with me I think because it's
philosophically pods with because it's
like I guess in moderate dose it's not
in like a good old white pint o gin yeah
like in moderate doses it it's designed
it you said like to take the edge off
mmm and I think that's just
philosophically at odds with a lot of my
life like I'm not really about comfort
you're out you're about lean is sitting
with you our journey sitting with the
air like I slept on the floor for two
years yeah like that's like the
philosophical side of it's not one that
I've really thought of we you really
correct with that the fact that people
say I use alcohol because it helps to
make me more confident on a night out
mm-hmm okay so you're not confident on a
night out no I am rock a what happens if
I remove the alcohol the alcohol is not
a part of you it's like me saying I can
run the hundred meters in one second if
I'm in a car Johnny's car can go a
hundred miles an hour I know what's to
come whether with and yeah like that's
one of the reasons that people say that
they drink they say it makes me more
personable and it makes me have more of
a laugh around my friends maybe that
right okay so your friends not funny if
you don't have a drink yeah
maybe say that round case or why are you
going out well I'm going out because my
friends want me to go out but I have to
drink because otherwise I'd be bored
okay so you're taking this substance to
sedate yourself from the fact that you
can't bear to be around people you're
choosing to be around without sedateness
normally around depressingly throat like
that it's like an interesting
experiments just I hate my life isn't it
well yeah I think for some people that
is the case but the so when I went out
some of the things I tried rounds at uni
and I was really heavily into like you
know calories you know alcohol calories
are metabolized differently the carbon
that I need to time it so I tried to
consume alcohol in a way that would you
know according to the science that I
understood at the time not store any of
it as body fat which was some really
extreme [ __ ] and what like well just
Meno Hensel ins front-loading all of it
so I didn't know fat during the day yeah
only protein only protein throughout the
day and then I basically did Centurion
with shots of vodka until I reached the
point where I was like I'm drunk enough
now then I left the house and drank only
water and got back and still hungover so
as though [ __ ] pointless but during
that time I tried going out so to see
what would be like and if you just
reframe it I was like everyone is
expecting me to be drunk if I just do
what I want if I'm just like Ringo
rhythms we're gonna do yeah like if you
just do that people go like people just
assume me like meant having a good time
so you can fully let go no one no one
owes you server anyway
and no one cannot be totally you know
Nizar notices so actually isn't the
reason why people are threatened if you
are sober is that I are Johnny's gonna
remember how much of it it's ghosts at
the police thing isn't it yeah like
people say like I and they're watching
that watching what I'm doing I'm
expressing myself but there's someone
there who's taking note but what does
that tell us about what's going on it
says that the behavior that I'm
currently doing because I'm drunk is
think that I don't want to remember or
might not be that virtuous yeah and the
only reason that I'm prepared to do it
is because I know that everybody else I
have as much [ __ ] on everyone else as
they have on me yeah plus the fact that
this that one of the side effects of
this drug is that memory kinda gets a
little bit hazy anyway what you said
about about nerfing kind of the edges of
stuff super interesting like that's what
it is isn't it it's nothing kinda
torpedoed twice the Sam Harris torpedoes
holidays yeah I used that Ezra Klein
thing isn't it as a example the other
day yes nothing the edges of the of your
experience yeah like it's [ __ ] now
man I think this is this probably
actually gets to why I think there's a
Fitness manopause in your late 20s which
you've undergone and you've undergone
and I've undergone and [ __ ] Darren as
Molly's going under God everyone has
that I know about that you get to later
in your 20s and you go like hang on I'm
not really growing or learning much more
from this particular training
methodology I want to be more holistic
in my approach to the way that I do my
fitness I'm gonna find I'm gonna find
something that is a little bit more
aligned with what I wanted a little bit
less sort of like look at me yeah yeah
yeah and then it's a second alcohol or
it was the same with alcohol for me
where I was like okay I've kind of I've
kind of maxed out what I'm gonna learn
from doing this thing every time I do it
take me to the same place and you
curbing the edges off all of the
interesting [ __ ] in life like even if
you were gonna get in a fight with
someone like if you're gonna get in a
fight or if that fights gonna happen you
might as well be sober and experience
what that level of fears actually like
as opposed to being like oh I think it
was a little bit like this but this
weird substance I decided to take to
kind of [ __ ] blasted me to one side
I've been I got nutted twice when I was
drunk and like in a row yeah yeah that's
it twice that punch in because I went
it's a long story but I was outside
venue in yeah it's coming is it really
Wow I've not been uttered when drunk but
I can imagine you feel the
and the movement dominoes are unheard I
type this thing I don't know I didn't
really feel anything I remember like our
happening and then there's like the like
module loading has got nothing it's
almost like okay so someone I knew had
this guy dropped a bottle that was brown
brown ale bottle and there was a there
was a argument erupted about how it was
racist
she's obviously ridiculous and I like I
like stepped in and said that come on
we're going to the next place and the
guy just went cracker and then so he
reasonably ended up the guy who netted
me ended up being put in a bin
upside-down by someone I know who's
involved in rugby a quite high level but
the whole thing was ridiculous but like
afterwards I just remember thinking like
it was so weird to have that happen and
obviously there'll be adrenaline and
stuff like that but you don't feel it at
all but you did thinking at the time I'm
glad it wasn't sort of hmm but just be
good because like that we would have
been very and Ozzy but yeah very similar
like you you just hear a noise like like
it's an Internet traffic or native stun
grenades yeah yeah flash mob and you
know yeah you don't feel the pain you
just like module loading
and then the other are not associated
next yeah it's it's interested like if
you were to design a drug this is like a
Hamilton Morris thing that he talked
about with alcohol how a Morrison's
pharmacopoeia a big Psychonauts loaded
like psychedelic release on the man but
he's not he's the opposite alright he's
the man behind big drug to Big Pharma
Antibes drugs and he talked about like
if you were going to design a drug it
would not be alcohol for the what was
the what's that thing dose the
therapeutic therapeutic dose amount is
[ __ ] huge the effects of it it's like
what do you want do you want memory loss
and lowered inhibitions a little bit of
aggressiveness and some kind of like
enhanced sadness and kind of lower sex
drive massive like anxiety rebound after
effect worse sleep worse like liver
function or all these things they're
just like how about how about having you
will power the next day completely
through the floor I'm cheering yeah yeah
so it's just like if you were to design
a drug alcohol would be a [ __ ] one and I
think what's interesting for you is
Yousef is that because you weren't
indoctrinated into this little [ __ ]
cabal of alcoholism when you were 18 and
you go to uni and you're like oh my god
I've got a flat in the halls of
residence and I can drink so you view it
as you view every other drug it's out
okay should I try it should I try
nicotine that I wondered have you ever
put a nicotine patch on the back half
not patch but I'm very keen to yeah you
just because I draw it like like what's
it called in us yes nurse it's knotting
it whatever just like try it what the
what happens
what's the therapeutic dose I will
choose to do very much yeah I've tried
nicotine gum German remember we're going
through a phase where nicotine gum was
advises like a fat loss I feel like what
I feel like awful is it like at my
coffee so it's like having a coffee but
more it feels more like a strong
nootropic there's like an edge it's more
of an edge to it how about Morris uses
nicotine gum as a writing tool I mean
like it definitely makes you
unlit but it's not I don't think it's a
nice a little done Bailey asked have you
ever smoked and he said yeah one stuff
to do like this seven-hour drive at
night and he's got 20 packing just like
what's this chain smoked them like in an
effort to keep himself awake Lucy that's
viewing it as a drug it's just the
smoking is a very inefficient delivery
mechanism just like drinking is an
inefficient delivery mechanism when you
think about like you know we talk about
other drugs on this podcast you talk
about the dosages that people have of
mushrooms grams of mushrooms or an
effective dose of cocaine part of like
grams at half a gram or quarter of a
gram or whatever or then you talk about
LSD and it's like micrograms single
micrograms right here and how much
[ __ ] that volume sheer volume of
alcohol it's so much if your body has to
excrete out the past stuff to make room
for more that's why I went for the gin
because I was like I cannot believe that
people get people go out and drink ten
beers of a drink that's fine air scent
okay like yeah like a social no
percentage is a horrible drink and you
drink you don't take ten pints of
anything and yet for some reason it's
normal to go out and drink five liters
of some kind of it's crazy that people
just don't like in any other
hyponatremic or something if you were to
go if I would like right we're gonna
walk in a go in this place tonight and
take a drug everyone's main concern
would be well how much am i taking like
if I'm gonna take a drug I want to know
like is the amount I'm taking all right
or am I gonna run into problems but
people just go into a bar and just how
about it don't they I think that's a lot
of that is because we know what the
dosage is right we can equate roughly
one double equals this much drunkenness
two doubles equals this much drunk on
tequila
you're like dealing with they're like
what happens once I've taken it as a
measure rather than whereas people
aren't like I take to power set them all
to get rid of my headache but I don't
like take the power set them all based
on how about my headache is hmm I just
take tell you the dosage of the drug
that isn't quite right people tell me
I'm approaching it all wrong and that's
why I'm not in
if not like that the installation yeah
they say like oh you shouldn't drink
thinking about the effect should you
just let the night flow and just have
you know so obviously I mean the
elephant in this room is that I make my
money from drug people I've done a
minute about a million people a million
customers go into my events nor that I
would guess 95 percent of them more were
drinking but again I don't have a
problem with drinking I don't think that
that's a bad thing
my problem is when you do that back and
forth like 30 years here 20 years even
10 years like throughout your 20s if all
that you do is live for the weekend and
be a weekend warrior you hit 30 and
you're like me what the [ __ ] you've
taken two steps forward and two steps
back every week your weight loss goals
aren't going anywhere
why do you think that is you've never
developed any good habits you sleep
still [ __ ] your mood still [ __ ] all
of the skills that you should have that
you can then double down on for the rest
of your life like confidence or the
ability to like approach anxiety the
ability to approach someone about the
same sex or a different sex your ability
to deal with anxious situations or in
certain situations that all of that plus
let's talk about cost on time cost on
money cost on calories the hangover the
next day all the mistakes the nuts not
even to talk about social cost how many
times did you cheat on your girlfriend
or get in a fight or [ __ ] lose your
keys or annoy someone or lose a friend
or [ __ ] whatever so the thing you
said about like you hit 13 you like oh
god I've kind of pissed away quite a lot
of money time and age it's actually yeah
like a lot of time piss in yeah and then
I'm out again and there's something you
mentioned before we started recording
it's like we're 13 though like
thereabouts
and I think this is the age where you
see people that you used to go to school
with if you haven't seen in maybe 10
years and for some of them you are like
I'm getting some UI or like paper around
the last decade man yeah what's happened
and I think it's because like at 16
years old you could do like were four
years old like all four year wasn't the
same like they can do whatever they
wanted if I made a flubber on you rubber
made of rubber and yeah
16 still the same thing like you can
can be like chain-smoker drink loads
like terrible lifestyle very resilient
you can do that then we can extend you
have your deadlifts yeah literally no
dogs mother who's just five years doctor
both yeah and then the cumulative effect
of that doesn't really manifest until
about thirty and then it's like my
biological age 50 yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was I was sending yourself a voice
no and I walk past someone who I've not
seen he didn't see me I've not seen him
for a long time and bad example of that
of behaviors that they gave yeah so
insidious cuz you don't think that it's
not graft from James clear where it's
like once and better every day is 38
times better by the end of the one
percent worse every day is not point not
one of what it was at the start of the
year and like they're always practicing
something the kid Lachlan thing yeah
you're always doing behaviors it's just
I think about babies yeah I think like
my I probably stand in between you see
one sobriety I'm drinking in general
like I still drink even after trying
sobriety because I think I just see as I
gets one of a hundred behaviors that you
do and it's more I think that where I
think the most benefit people get from
giving something up is like what that
thing is masking or what you do that
thing instead of what you do that thing
to like escape from a feeling or escape
from a thought or like a part of your
life and when you strip it away and you
have to then deal with that for me
that's when it's because I it's the
underlying thing yeah the real meat of
it is like it's you know people how long
do people spend on the phones why are
they doing that it's not like is being
when your phone about then yes it's not
great use of time but then like is
watching TV it so many other things its
are you like ignoring a conversation or
its what is underneath that cuz you
can't sit with your thoughts it's
because you can't back exactly yes
whatever and I think you spend a lot of
time have spent a lot of time hundreds
of hours of time of meditating which is
like the opposite right it's dealing
with what's there for an insane
surprising interface days with it which
is the opposite drinking which is
running away from what's the
trying to round the edges off so it's
not quite sharp Oh interesting as well
it doesn't appeal as I'm already rounded
fossil wood balsa quickly from eyeball
the boss of it but but I think like it's
it's maybe because it's so contrary to
the artists I feel like why would I want
to yeah
but interesting quote on what you've
just said from Anthony de Mello who is a
Jesuit preacher priest whatever he said
whenever the priest comes to me asking
for refuge and help all he wants to do
is talk about sex when the prostitute
comes to me all they want to do is talk
about God so he's like it's not about
the thing it's like whatever you
renounce you bring back into your life
ten things because you're pushing it
away or pulling it towards you in some
way such an interesting yes what well
you have this I mean Johnny no one even
knows this means you only have the same
meditation coach now mm-hmm and Brian
talks about not not fixating or
suppressing like me that's what
equanimity is yeah yeah it's not wanting
more of a good thing or less of a bad
thing
yes yeah yeah it's it and that's that's
exactly what you're talking about that
so what what did you learn from three
months of sobriety did it reframe
anything for you ah I think it made it
made alcohol seem more like an option
rather than a default so make drinking
seem like you know if I want to go to an
event that I would normally just drink
up that's but so it's like I'm trying to
give an example it's like a it's I think
for a lot of people myself included it's
an automatic behavior it's not you don't
have a thought of like I'm going out
this evening and I'm gonna have three
beers yeah you just find that happening
yeah but I would have thought because
you have to plan your taxi and not
driving is a default no it's yeah it's
like you're going out with friends so
yeah it'll be food and some drinks or
we're going to a bar so there'll be
drinks passengers because I maybe I'm so
out of the habit if for me I would have
to be like alright consciousness because
I can't drive I think it depends as well
on I which circle you're in because
obviously like when we go for food and
like when
we're a modern will rarity though yeah
but that not because I remember George
saying it was luck was like this time
last year so it's so weird to go for
food with creeper guys and not drink
because I'll go through that same
situation with a group of other people
and it's like weird if you've not had to
be at my midday because that's their
default but it's a bit I think quite
dependent on who you're with because
there there are people who just don't
drink because that's what they prefer
and some people feel like it's so rad a
man like yeah very rare 30 like and then
I guess maybe as you move a little bit
further on but it seems to me to be the
few people that do and this is an ED
Lattimore ISM right Theo alcohol is the
only drug where if you don't do it
people assume you have a problem yeah
and that's why so many people I think
have it this aversion to going sober
sobriety seen as something that song you
don't when someone has an issue with
alcohol and can't be a lifestyle choice
like this the this the backlash that you
get when you don't drink like do you get
social backlash to get people like
assuming you have a problem or trying to
get you to drink trying to like get you
to join the did when I started the did
when I started I'm like fairly sort of
well stance now is the sobriety guy or
the guy the guy that does periods of
sobriety is up trying to like but not
even that it's like I think a lot of
people are very timid about let's say
that they've got something on the next
morning you you go into it that people
have to go into it [ __ ] caveats and
litigation about why they're not
drinking yeah or mate well I've got I've
got doctor's appointment at 10:00 in the
morning like oh maybe that's not even
the truth but they have to do it because
I've brought the car like oh I know some
people who take their car keys out with
them without the car really so they can
go I've got the car man I don't drink
and it's like that's how is the
equivalent that I've got a boyfriend
it is but it neutralizes that
conversation quickly because people are
like oh I'm prepared to push you if I
think it's your will but the certain
things I'm not prepared to push you on
but people are prepared to push you if
they think it's your will I'd like wine
and again I get it we are all here the
clocking out of this podcast whether
this breaks down the podcasting schedule
again
today's episode went up with Paul bloom
and he does this video guy being picked
out the best experiment in that I wonder
if you know about this psychology
experiment they put people in a room
they get all of them to toss a coin by
law of averages but half of them go over
there half and go over their tails group
heads group and they go over to the
tails group and what do you think of
yourselves then power so some were a bit
smarter doesn't it if you what do you
think about the heads could be higher I
could got a bit but you dicks over there
just a lot of schmoes hmm and it's like
the most random arbitrary way and to
split people up into us and them and it
causes people to make value judgments
yeah that's because for the vast
majority of evolutionary history were in
groups of 25 to 50 and we were [ __ ]
terrified of what was in the next Valley
because they were gonna kill us
rape our women they had some pathogen
that we weren't going to be able to
[ __ ] deal with because there was no
idea biotics or whatever it might be we
were terrified of it and that's still
the module that's in that's so funny I'm
even on that because I rotate between
medical and surgical jobs and those are
people not then I ask the [ __ ]
surgeons like there's just there are
bloody medics always just refer anyone
with abdominal pain to us yes it's it's
in everything kill each other other
stuff yeah yeah well collisions the
biggest one isn't tribalism man you
don't plant the flag in the ground but
it's like here is he's one of us he's
drinking with us
he's an effect hang on a second if
you're [ __ ] and Niall ating yourself
and taking two steps back this weekend
if you were that good of a friend you'd
support me in my cause for sobriety so
that was like one of the main questions
or one of the main issues people have
when they go sober is how do I do this
when all of my friends around me drink
inside well it'll identify exactly who
the friends are there in your life are
good for you yeah because the ones who
are like [ __ ] hell man you train that
like if you explain your reasons really
you're gonna [ __ ] out well like that
blame out as opposed to what though you
know coming out you think you're better
than us like what you're not coming out
any second
your best interests at heart they don't
care they only want you there if you're
destroying yourself with them and if you
can only bear to be around your friends
when you're drunk like you definitely
need better friends . i think it comes
from so that i I have some friends who
sometimes don't drink and they are
boring-ass in when they do that like not
not just because they're sober but I
think it's because they're in this
mindset of like I'm not really fully
participating here they leave early
they're not there a bit you know that
reserved yeah you such a good example
like he's there and he'll be there till
it finishes whatever things finishes
yeah he's not drinking and you can't you
don't even notice in fact he's probably
more like inhibit even in its
uninhibited that other people who are
drinking but that's a lot of that is to
do with the fact that you've never had
to rely yeah alcohol to be that crooks
to make them sociable but you've
developed that particular pathway to be
like I can be here and I can not drink
but I can also be a part of this group
but I've been on nights out with you and
you're not drinking
Ben's another good example like I just
they're they're not drunk but I still
being so I'm a good time I still
engaging in it and I think where this
for me anyway where I'll have a
resistance to it is if some people say
I'm bringing the car just like you feel
like saying look just don't just don't
come because you don't you don't really
want to be there yeah you're just kind
of doing half so that no one gives you
[ __ ] but I think it's for some people it
feels like there's a shift in the way
that they act when it's my right I'm not
bringing the car all right if [ __ ] you
know on it boy it's like there's no
reason why you can't just be like that
it's like the thing I was saying with
the nightclub like once you realize that
it's all an illusion anyway and that you
can't just be how you want and if people
judge you them but they're gonna judge
it either way to just have a good time
yeah and then people will give you last
[ __ ] if you're just an interesting
person really serve isn't and so you
again you super right with that that
alcohol is still controlling that person
who's chosen to go sober but is being
super reserved they're still controlling
their behavior they're just now
controlling their behavior what by its
absence rather yeah by its prey
Sasebo effect as well a lot of people
like yeah there was that thing where
they gave people an alcoholic Dre I gave
two like two tables not alcoholic beer
and I'll call a doctor the same I think
they measured like how much of the food
they ate missing that one no they might
they gave them like onion rings and
stuff and getting men to get gotten to
rate that perceived drunkenness and how
much of the food there and it wasn't
that different right interest just crazy
mental it's like if you're drinking
non-alcoholic beer there is a similar
like I've had times I've drunk an
alcoholic beer and got in the car and
thought oh [ __ ] but then you're at me
like it's ludicrous like a bit you know
like glowing on kind of put alcohol in a
non-alcoholic beer am i I mean this is
big seeds are being [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's a there's a petite I was gonna
do a YouTube video on this but I
couldn't do it without just essentially
calling people out by name so I'll try
and I've tried to navigate this like
five times before I just gave up I have
a problem with YouTube may not be
exposed to this because you're not
massively exposed to party culture but
people listening will know this person
or these people guys specifically mostly
guys who have this semi flirtatious
almost like gay candor before they go on
a night out talking about how heavy the
night's going to be say or may can't
wait to shut down Newcastle tonight
horn emoji horn emoji aubergine emoji
like or do you remember last time we're
in that it's like hey you got are you
going in there and rubbing up against
each other or something like that what
are you doing on your night out that
makes you think that you have license to
use this sort of language in advance
this isn't done bilzerian's [ __ ]
Villa you're unloading yourself into the
[ __ ] Playboy Mansion here you are
going on a night out to sit in the
corner be nervous about talking to them
complain because George George didn't
put five pounds in for the bottle of
vodka like yeah that that's the
complaint the oven I see these people
just breaking the same guys who give it
massive licks before they go on a night
out
yeah man it's gonna be [ __ ] sick
tonight like you know they have this
like weird dick-measuring thing going on
before where it's like yeah like you
think that you're gonna run rings around
me but just you wait till we get in them
it's like you yeah you're drinking you
this is assuming a commercially
available drug this isn't the Abu Dhabi
f1 like you know far outside of a
reference book cuz I would have thought
like oh I want to get as drunk as
possible for as cheaply as possible I
want to be the lightest weight person in
the group because yes interesting this
being a lightweight is seen as a bad
thing when actually he's got three
pounds and again it's rite-of-passage
it's like look I'm able to drink this
much because I've drank this much before
and more
it's very self referential as know yeah
yeah it's the it's interesting though
like because that fuels the same thing
if you break from that your friends are
like well no but you've got to be like
us again and and it's like well yeah it
does differentiate the people that I
don't not necessarily they they have bad
intentions but they just they prioritize
their own sense of security over what's
best for you and it's why like I'm so
I'm so grateful to to Johnny for like
for being supportive of the fact because
I obviously we text quite a lot to
proclaim stuff but Johnny was probably
one of the only people that was like
wholeheartedly supportive of me getting
rid of my phone game I can knock you
three 310 even though he would be the
person who be in quantifiably it was the
most in the short term would be most
impacted by it but I suppose like
probably because you like I've seen
their secrecy man the long time but yeah
but the line Tony hunt doors box yeah
yeah yeah it's so I think um to go back
to why people don't one of the fears
that people have about going sober it's
a well if I don't drink then all of my
friends are going to say why you're not
drinking it's gonna be social pressure
maybe I'll stop getting invited out to
what have a lot how do I the question I
get a lot is out how do you deal with
social pressure you're around people who
are drunk all the time
how do you deal with it and
for the most part I think the same as
with a lot in life it's like if you say
things with conviction people will go
[ __ ] it up it's like when I first
started doing sobriety I was very open
about my reasons I was like I want more
time to spend on some other stuff and
I'm challenging myself to see if I can
do it
mm-hmm like I'm challenging myself to
see if I can do it turns it from you
abstaining from something to you adding
something it's like I'm trying to
achieve this thing so I'm gonna make why
going out for that morning run I'm doing
it marathon you want to train for the
marathon I want to see if I can do it
it's like why you're not drinking oh
well I want to see if I can not go sober
six months and I found like I'm the
patient [ __ ] zero for being exposed
to people who want you to drink there's
no top top point one of the percentile
on the globe of people of humans that
have been exposed to drunk people I'll
be in easily a special handshake for
keeping people away from me when I try
and the track [ __ ] come in together
see if I can do it and if I can do it
with conviction and you can maybe sail
while you're in a position of authority
for the club stuff maybe that kind of
means that people are less pushy
but it's [ __ ] I sit down with with a
lot of people new people and blah blah
blah
missiny she explained her I just wanted
a bit more time or money or go just want
to challenge myself see if I can do it
and then people seem to be really
responsive which if you do it with
confidence yeah it shines a light back
on them that isn't it it's like when you
see cut examples of couples we're like
one of them will get in shape or one of
them are like higher at PT and start
losing weight and it like kisses the
other one off because it immediately
alienates alienates but it also like
they're forced to deal with their lack
of progress in that area people don't
like to see other people growing around
them exactly now they're only they're
only happy if you're destroying yourself
with them and this this is like one of
for me you know by fortune or whatever
my circles always been sort of fairly so
in any case I've never had influence
that kind of been that negative by see
it with a lot of people madam it's bad
man like that that's the literally
talking about your life like that
someone's [ __ ] around with the values
that you lead your life by yeah that
person could have said to you hey man
like I watch this podcast with that
modern wisdom thing and they talked
about going sober like a fancy Chuck
trying to do for a bit and should we do
try January or whatever and your
response to that person could be the
beginning of them making a really
interesting change to their life or it
could be now I'm like [ __ ] that like
it's it's it's it's John OHS 30-second
like you can't you can't miss John or
30-second he's going to York for it
like just what what do you mean what do
you mean we're going to York but again
the John of 32nd is 31st was [ __ ]
[ __ ] like June I mean yeah yeah yeah
very repetitive I don't know I think the
this is definitely something that I know
that we all do is like there's something
you do as a behavior so I write to try
and not do that
I love doing caffeine sleeping in a bed
that masturbation phone use is the
latest one phone use social social media
and that's my latest like yeah still
don't feel like I'm sleeping late
sleeping in all sorts of stuff yeah you
take yeah not you take that yep well
just how I think people do dry January
and you'll sit you'll see it happen as
January rolls around like people's
social media fills up with I can't wait
for you know people put those countdown
timers on there it's until when they get
to have a drink again and then they go
back out it just is in it just as an
intense fashion and like realistically
all you've done you know this is
renouncing something and then bringing
it back harder into you yeah I think
we've done it you may be given
internally a month of arrests those
systems like what if that especially if
you go harder when you go back oh yeah
the first the first couple of weekends
where you compensate yeah it's like
those conference it's like the person
that using intermittent fasting
yes like oh I won't eat for today but
I'll eat triple tomorrow yeah no no you
know the people who are like there's all
the stuff about it's Friday so it's
Prosecco time or you can't wait for
Saturday when I'm it was a club the
exact like that that stuff that is in my
view like those are the people that need
a year off it you need time to realize
maybe calibrated just just or it feels
like you are using you are using a drug
to cover up parts of your life that
maybe aren't right at the moment but
you're using the use of a drug to
determine your week your weekly cares
yeah do you mean like it must sound like
to some people are listening like a lot
of the things that we talk about it must
sound so [ __ ] artistic for us to just
be like you know this thing that's taken
for granted by everyone what we'd really
like to do is find out what's going on
magnifying glass like but it is like I
promise you for the people that are
listening like if you would think to
yourself is a good question to ask like
when was the last time you didn't drink
for more than six months before even a
week for some people yeah okay well the
last time we didn't drink for a week
when was last time you didn't drink
apart from pregnancies for women when
was last time you didn't drink for a
month and when was last time you didn't
drink for six months and that six month
distribution will be the most of the
people that are listening before they
start drinking yeah let's hide you you
just give it someone told you upon the
day that you arrived on this earth
you're gonna have this drug from the age
of 16 until the time you die more
frequently than once every six months or
more frequently than once every month
offer some people more frequently than
once every week you'd be like is this is
this like mandatory is this like a part
of to have to sign this off it's part my
memory a life or something you know the
supersize vs. super-skinny thing where
they they take someone who's super sized
and they go she was what you've eaten in
a week and they show it all on it in a
big room yeah yeah super skinny is like
50 Red Bulls and like some
fees yeah loads packed a cigarette
that's someone who's figured out that
caffeine is quite good for appetizer
yeah often a drug doesn't like a female
and then like the fat the fat person has
just got piles of like pasties and yeah
beige isn't it big yeah yeah what colors
yeah and if you were to do that with the
alcohol ahead of time and also you have
like a big blown up from 3d rotating
image of your liver and just showing
like how its game mmm so roast over the
years you'd be like oh actually because
I so I think if we were sat here now
probably not you included will include
the VLE if we were to have four beers I
think we'd all enjoy the four of years
mm-hmm
apart from you yeah the fifth beer hmm
six beer maybe not it tapers down I
think quite quickly I didn't like the
process of you're in a bar with your
mates trying yeah but you have a couple
of years it's it's quite nice right when
you start getting spicy words it is when
you start getting silly with it was
right all along but I passed then really
it's just all don't [ __ ] but everyone so
this tooth is too like little cliches
that I've come up with since thinking
about this one of them is that every
drink you have makes not having a
subsequent drink more difficult yeah
everyone's been out and one wine turns
into a couple of beers sent into a
bottle of vodka turns into a kebab at
3:00 in the morning
everyone's let it go were like there's
even that super [ __ ] meme about I
just popped out yeah now ended about I
mean there's no yeah and then the other
thing that I realized I keep meaning to
make a graph about this but um alcohol
gives you diminishing margins of return
in terms of pleasure but gives you
exponential increase in terms of
suffering so ten beers doesn't double
your enjoyment from five beers but it
more than doubles your suffering the
next day and it starts to become really
quite serious actually either any anyone
who's hard like so I think if we're
talking pints
over seven and you're into some real
quite serious territory there like
that's a lot of volume I need to visit
there's a glass ceiling that I bound
but unless I get spirits out yeah like
there's only because you just limited
gastrointestinal e yeah like just as a
mechanical yeah arrows yeah I could just
fit so much in and I'm sick it it's like
I can make myself full enough to want to
throw up if I'm allowed to have dessert
I couldn't do it just say so this is
like the extreme case but imagine like
this is a spectrum that you get some yet
patients in hospital that their entire
calorie intake three thousand two
hundred calories a day which I worked
out and the fight is the amount of
spirit that they're drinking and it's
just that every day so they'll just
spirits this out vodka 3,000 calories of
vodka read their protein
no no protein one another quite do you
don't know me very lean or with like it
with a bit of a swollen but like to get
3,000 calories a day of spirit and so
you end up having to give them like
replacement vitamin injections I was
like an urgent thing because they're so
deprived on there we got scurvy and
stuff like yeah we got yep there's
something called pattern X which is just
like they're like big bit like walking
dose of vitamin replacement Baraka is
that like what's like is it not come for
getting people out of opiate oh I see
opiates oh no these that's narcan that
they use it's a nasal spray that just
binds to the receptors but it binds it
binds harder than the drugs do but
that's the when you give that you have
to like run out the room because look it
up punch it they get really angry yeah
yeah oh yeah oh really thought why yeah
it's just you've just wasted forgive the
yeah cuz I just cut it just stops too
high and they have they're having a
great time but there are seeing
respiratory depression and you like top
rigorously
and you give them the feel like you
usually that's like either like tie them
to the bed or something okay eternity
policeman so it tastes it tastes like I
love how this hit taser twice I don't
know why it's just completely like if
you have to shout taser and then you're
gonna get tasered the second days ER at
that point is just well you know it's
you know it's coming to them
you know mean exercise right yeah it
cosmos because there'll be loads of
times where you might say the word taser
once and there
[ __ ] fair enough waiting for this
waiting for the second phase like if you
have a policeman you just shut a zit and
everyone's just have you ever been
tasered someone in college had a hunt
held one oh I'm talking about the stone
gun like um it put me on the floor in
the back in the hamstring like it just
not immediately like just Crump's you up
disabled yeah yeah yes like the fact
that the fact that it's the people use
that as a controlling thing didn't
surprise me if it's so inhibiting maybe
but hey it's also it's mine isn't there
a video of a guy it just to getting
tasered he just deals with it
he's like a jerk I'm terrified yeah do
you think like it's alright in the UK
because we've got tased you know you
need taser taser taser well at that
point they just use like you know like
the crowd control that they rub the
bullets yeah is it Lee Sanchez whether
you they try out all the different like
familiar thing and the spray it was the
one where they it shoots a little bag
have you seen that one it Sunday Sanchez
it shoots like a tiny little hard
bargain like that like a beanbag oh yeah
once came back from an after-party and
once came back to our after-party in
abathur to find Pritchard um in our
barbecue Kilner Pritchard from dirty
sanchez in our BBQ kiln then he jumped
off the roof of the villa into the pool
and maybe bro feels like those guys have
a really great Irie Envy about you know
he's doing know like a lot of hardcore
I'm on and try I'm not stir fry and he's
like really good here he's like really
really good phoenix tree in person if
you can tolerate that kind of pain for
for I don't think it's funny you know
you know they said the most painful
thing that they'd ever ever done was you
see when they jumped into nettles I've
have seen that yeah to the most painful
thing that really yep well they're
working them
putting them on the balls I know so is
it as naked paintball and stuff on there
but suppose at that point like one that
got showing the dick yes got shot on the
shot on that yeah without favourite ones
where they put a guy's asleep and then
put like an electric and bounded dog
collar on it oh so it whenever he tries
to leave the sofa
it's a look at like ring-fenced around
his neck and he can't get it off there's
a video from Tough Mudder when this guy
so you know in tough mudder the final
bit electroshock therapy there's some of
them that have got ten million volts in
I don't know this it's a summer yeah but
if the amp the amputee other what did
you whatever's really love but the
voltage is super high so yeah it floors
people but there's a there's maybe let's
say there's five hundred of these little
threads it's not when you under under
there Isis it like surely have you know
so imagine imagine a bunch of different
pieces of string that is twenty feet
wide by fifty feet long and you have to
they're all dangling there's five
hundred pieces of strength let's say the
wires let little wires and you have to
run through the wires some of the wires
have no voltage some of them are
basically non some of them have enough
to her and some of them have this ten
mil and you have to you have to go
through them in so there's some some
different strategies this strategy to do
it I've asked the guy who created Tough
Mudder course is to run through it as
fast as possible yeah because the way
that watch works is it's like a
capacitor it goes up and then discharges
it goes up and then discharges so if you
move very
slowly you'll get a phone you'll end up
getting it at some point because you'll
be touching all of them at the point
that they discharged and there's this
one video of this guy he's like running
and he gets like clocked by this one
it's right the very end gets clocked by
this one but they're about that far off
the floor so then he's on the floor face
down in this mud and then every time
that he pushes himself up it just gets
him again
so just goes the point where it's like
it was health well let's make you wait
yeah actually it's like creeks creeping
forward like half a foot each time
that's really made me reframe the tough
mother like I thought it was like
running with the other effort like an
arrow yes it's a good distance it's like
a 15k as well anyway there's so much
more that we've got to talk about first
sobriety and we've done often off-topic
as always but if anyone wants to find
out a little bit more if you head to six
months sober calm slash podcast you can
find out a little bit of info or just
give me a DM if you have me in questions
of thoughts about what we've talked
about actress were likes on all social
media just give me a DM I'm happy to
give you a little bit of advice about
how I think you could go dry for January
or if you're watching this in 2022 in
the middle of June or something just
drop me a message and we'll see where we
go from there
thanks for amateurs
[Music]
you